can
machines be creative
it's an interesting question creativity
is wrapped up a lot in romance kind of
there's this idea that um
creativity is kind of linked with
the human spirit and expression the kind
of
epiphany of thoughts and that kind of
artist out to sea for some inspiration
suddenly has that like blinding light
going in their head
and that idea strikes them well
there certainly is romance in being
creative
but there is also a lot of stuff going
on subconsciously that we're not aware
of there's a lot of processing there's a
lot of
background noise going on inside our own
brains influences
that are affecting how we come up with
ideas and
while creativity is romantic i kind of
find it quite romantic
knowing how stuff works so i quite like
to know how creativity works
but then we hit our first sticker what
is
creativity and surprisingly there are
many definitions
but for the sake of this i'm going to
just give you a brief
description of what i mean when i'm
going to say creativity it's really
divided into two different types
psychological creativity
me as an individual with all my
experiences
can come up with a new idea that i
myself have never ever had
but someone else might have had it this
is the fun
problem of going to github and having
this really exciting project and going
oh
right someone's already done that
historical creativity
is a bit of a bigger deal throughout the
history of the human race
no one has ever had this thought before
so already as humans historical is a
tiny tiny percentage it's the leonardo
da vinci's the most out of the box
who have had radical ideas that have
fundamentally changed the way we
function as humans
so historical is a very
very far goal for any sort of ai system
psychological maybe that's possible
we're starting with creativity we start
with these boundaries
and this circle represents the kind of
creative space
the black boundary represents the rules
the grammar you have in your head that
limits you in the way you express
yourself so
let's take an example of like portrait
painting so within a portrait
there's already constrictions around the
fact that you need a person you might
have like just a face shot
and all these various rules about what
paint you use what colors you use
kind of limits your creative space
and there's a couple of ways we can be
creative the way we can create
ideas so the first one is simple
combination
we take two very well-known ideas they
don't have to be new
and join them such that they create a
new concept
so but this is pretty common in
programming languages i think of
things like ruby that took ideas from
small talk
python bits of haskell but lots of bits
and kind of joined these all together
they weren't necessarily new ideas but
it did create something new from
joining those the other is
exploration so i said we have this
this semantic space expiration is with
all the rules trying to find every weird
and wonderful possible thing you could
express
so i think of this of like brainstorming
now in both these two forms of coming up
with ideas
machines are brilliant at exploration
space at high permutation depth
exploring a massive number of
permutations and in terms of combination
again that's a combinatorial problem
machines can be pretty good at that they
can process a lot more than
i could process but the key essence is
knowing when you found something of
value
and that's the running challenge for ai
is to not just
search but to know when you've struck
gold
the final form is perhaps the most
coolest
as humans this is where you
look at your own internal rules adjust
them
and change them such that you can
express
a new idea a new concept that was
impossible to express
in this previous rules you bend the
space you bend the rules
analogy for this one i think of kind of
transitioning from
something to the closure programming
language which i do a lot of
and suddenly there's different ways of
expressing ideas there's sometimes ways
of expressing things that you couldn't
have expressed before
very simple things that can have quite a
dramatic effect on the ideas and how
creative you can be
so there's a brief overview of
creativity
now let's explore how machines can be
creative and what currently exists
one of the um most interesting i guess
leaps in ai creativity
was understanding the importance of
entropy and chaos
this came from an idea of
training a neural network with every
possible
movement that the human body could make
kind of advance as such
and then by introducing slowly killing
those connections while the neural
network was running
you introduced a little bit of chaos a
little bit of randomness
if you think about that kind of
transformational um creativity
suddenly the system was doing stuff that
we didn't tell it to do making
associations that we didn't tell it to
do
and because we're kind of only killing a
couple of neurons it has a very
spiked effect it's still following a lot
of the rules but suddenly those rules
have changed slightly
and from this came um what they called
the death dance
which i'll show you
i still keep challenging someone to
actually try and do this it should be
possible
but i'm not going to do it now kind of
beautiful i think our next artist
is aaron aaron is a painter
aaron mixes his own paintbrushes
cleans their brushes and
often is left running overnight painting
on a canvas with a brush
i think kind of doing about 10 to 20
pictures overnight
people seem to be obsessed with the
detail that aaron cleaned its own
brushes
here's an example of some of the pieces
of i say art
that aron has made the creator is um
harold cohen
and the idea for aaron came from
something very simple he was wondering
um i'm not sure in a national park of
some kind and came across
some very basic cave paintings and he
wanted to answer the question
when do some marks on a wall become a
figure become a picture
and like good computer scientist he
completely obsessed with that for 40
years
and built aeron aron is based on
one core idea that
what we store inside our brains is a
much
is a reduced representation of the
constructs we have in this world
so the example of this is when you look
at me
actually for the first split second or
even more
than the seconds what you see is my
shape you see the outline of a human
being
and then your categorization in your
head is okay that's a human and then you
start flinging the details looking at
all the other various details
so the idea with aaron is by having a
very simple representation
of objects in the world that's enough
for it to project and start creating and
painting
to give you an example of how aron
functions
it starts um for example there's an
element of randomness initially about
what it's going to paint
but that is heuristically weighted in
that it's not going to paint a ginormous
head
on the canvas because it knows that's
going to make it very hard
to fit other things into the picture to
add to the composition
so it starts with the idea i want to
paint a figure
it knows the figure has a body a head
arms legs
it moves on to the next step of okay
those aspects of the human
have different ratios it could be thin
fats large lots of
various aspects which again it's going
to decide upon
then it moves on to positions that the
human body can move it needs to know
every possible position that a human
could move in in order to
accurately create a human and finally it
thinks about the environment
uh gravity so the simple idea that if a
character was standing in a strange
position looking like they would be
floating in mid-air we would
have a strain it would have a strange
feel to it um
funnily enough one of the hardest things
that aaron actually did sure if my laser
pointers working that well here
is in the very top um occlusion the idea
of having one person behind another
person
is actually a very difficult concept and
came quite far
in um aaron's progression i think these
pieces
i'm not sure which ones but i know some
of them have hung in the moma in
san francisco and have been around a
couple of galleries again
lots of contention over whether this is
art and whether this is creativity
now i'm kind of fun to explore what's
out there but i
want to dig a little deeper and explore
music and see how far we can get
in creating something that may create
creative music there's a lot of crates
in there i should precursor this
with i am absolutely obsessed with
sound i like every second of my life is
full of music
but i have absolutely no pretension to
create music
at all i'm still the scar from the fact
that no matter how hard i blew in a
saxophone it didn't make a sound and
this has stayed with me to my adulthood
so i cannot for the life of me
create music i'm very very bad so
please anyone who has any formal music
training come up to me afterwards and
absolutely break me and rip me to shreds
because i will learn so much from it and
i'm open-minded about it so join me with
this
journey hello and welcome to the
wonderful world
of sound
noticeably sound not music initially at
least
complexity a programmer's best friend
if we're creating music maybe if we
create something sufficiently
complicated enough
we could argue that that could be
creative you know i couldn't
when the complexity gets so great i may
not even be able to predict what it's
going to generate
so let let's try that as an avenue to
explore
all these examples of written enclosure
using overtone
i'm going to start with something very
simple let's take a little bit of
mathematics
take cosine and all we're going to do
is there's not even any linearization
we're just going to take simple numbers
the map to pitches
and play them on a piano
not really music i had a thinking about
that search space it was literally
following a directed path right there
was no creativity there
celia automa are a fun way of creating
very complex systems
so in here there's just simple rules
about whether cells live or die
and there's a representation um i just
created here where the dot
means that a cell is alive we always
start with one cell being alive
and what we're going to do is map these
two pictures on a piano
or augusta
sounds very ominous
again it's it's not really music there's
definitely a lot of complexity there's a
lot of symmetry
overtone gives us a way to tell computer
shut up which is going to be very useful
for this presentation
let's jump in and have a brief look at
what um the cellular tomorrow looks like
it's simply a set of rules about stars
and
zeroes indicating whether three stars
dies
two stars live and i played around with
lots
and lots of different rules just to hear
what they sounded like
and we just work out with us very simple
one dimensional grid
that processes three by three by three
by three to see whether sales live or
die
i have another fun cellular autonomous
rules that i kind of like
[Laughter]
i actually quite like this one it's
still not music but
there's a certain symmetry to it that
maybe is touching on something relating
to music
again we can talk over time to shut up
so let let's try a different data set
this time i'm going to focus on a huge
source of random data
so i'm going to take satellite data i
believe
from mexico
and this is literally just a whole
massive bunch of integer values
i'm going to linearize these onto piano
pictures
and maybe that randomness would do
something interesting
[Music]
yeah there's not much music in
randomness it's interesting it's
nice to represent data as sound but it's
again not music
maybe we can use something that has a
better probability distribution that
might be more effective
as music words are pretty good we have a
consistency of vowels
so i can take these words on letters and
map them to pictures
so this is what a strange loop sounds
[Music]
like
it's very ominous it's literally like
each character maps uppercase lowercase
maps to a pitch
and again we discover something
interesting here the word potato has a
beautiful pita patter to it
it's again like a good probability
distribution there's definitely
some of that order is bringing us
something closer to music
but we're still quite a long way away so
complexity has given us something
interesting but
i wouldn't call it music yet
perhaps we try another path and capture
humans because humans are supposed to be
creative right so
maybe if we can capture some of that
essence in a machine
it might start to sound more like music
i start with a neural network that's a
great way of encoding
a lots and lots of users representations
of feelings towards music
this is constructing a very simple
progression of notes and graded on how
pleasant people found the transitions
yeah it's getting better we're
definitely moving towards
a pattern but it lacks a lot of human
feel
markov chains using probability models
are also
a great way of encapsulating part of a
human's
use of music just creating a probability
tree based on what the previous notes
were
and using that to try and decide what
the future notes will be
i have a couple of examples just a very
simple one
using i think like six or seven notes
but we need a big data set for this to
be useful so instead i'm going to use
a bunch of music by buck i have a
file here with a breakdown by pitch and
by time
of a lot of buck music and i'm going to
use this to create a probability tree
which i'm then going to generate music
from
initially i'm only going to use a single
note so it's only based on the previous
note
to decide how this music sounds and i
also give it the first note so it can
actually stop
better it's becoming music but there's a
couple of bum notes there still
what we can do is expand the depth of
our markov chain so rather than
considering one note consider three
notes
we get closer fit to bach so we're
closing that expiration space but we're
becoming better focused on what's good
again it's about assessing the value of
whether we're finding interesting things
[Applause]
starting to sound a little bit more like
music we're
definitely making progress but it's a
very tight
fit right i mean again we're just using
box genius to try and reshuffle into
music
an interesting idea but it's still not
getting us a lot of things
all these solutions really we've kind of
encoded
lots of rules which the machine is
executing we haven't really
created anything that's making leaps
that's making bounds that's discovering
new things
i got obsessed with this idea of
it's an idea that was created by
i believe the inventor of the air harp
who created that for bjork
he had a couple of ideas about how you
could take the human subconscious and
use that to generate music and also use
it to control music
and i thought this would be kind of fun
to try
so just out of curiosity i acquired a
test subject
it took a while but uh this is my
daughter
and i decided to very very briefly
i wouldn't recommend doing anything like
this for any sort of amount of time
very very briefly decided to scan her
brain waves
and something very felt very good about
the fact that
she would generate brain waves which
would feed into the computer the
computer would play back the
instantaneous music to her
that would affect her brain waves which
would change
and there's this quite beautiful loop
going on right a little bit like our
subconscious mind
i use um a little python script which is
taking data
off a eeg machine that i actually have
sitting over there
and it's feeding that via a socket in
fact i'll grab it
just to make you think i don't just put
my daughter through this i'll do it as
well
let's see how this thing goes on i think
this looks better than google classes
so it connects over the socket and then
it's pushing
um data to closure where i'm just
reading them through the name socket
and there's a huge amount of information
here so there's
infinite fun to be had playing with this
but at the moment i'm just doing a
linear map
which turns out to be not that effective
more interesting things about power laws
but
and i'm also mapping the attention
because i figure
a small child has very little attention
so it might be more interesting
and this is what my daughter's brain
sounds like
[Music]
so a bit of fun but uh again
it's it's hard sometimes to turn data
into music so this is where i turn
to the um i guess the leaders and
experts in musical creativity
which is david cope um the author of
these two books computer models of
musical creativity
and virtual music computer synthesis and
musical style
and these are gonna take us in leaps and
bounds to actually
get even closer to what might be
creative music
from this we're going to define an
integrated model of musical creativity
the very first step is probably defining
what of some of david cope's ideas are
around music
his theory is that no music
comes about from nothing from a vacuum
in fact originality in music is often
about composing
other influences in such a way that they
create a new unique sound
and through this we can use illusions
this is a
very simple swell very simple it's
reasonably simple
script that will take a source data set
uh in this example we're going to use a
bit of music from chopin
and we'll try and find influences from
other composers
so i have a whole bunch of uh composers
here it's going to generate
um not comparisons by pitches but by
comparison by intervals
and from this we can start to get a
little insight into perhaps how chopin
was influenced
i'll jump to the music so the top score
represents chopin's original piece
and each other piece is the pattern
that matched with chopin's music and
this
could give evidence to suggest that
chopin was influenced by bach
beethoven and various other composers
this is interesting in kind of moving
with
um david cope's theory of music is a
recombination of existing forms of music
but this also provides a very powerful
way of
merging different sources of music we
saw in the markov chain how we kind of
did
just took box music and used that to
generate new music
using some sort of pattern matching
system we can take
two disparate source of music and by
finding a pattern
that may match that may be influenced we
might find a good point to take those
two pieces of music and join them
together
so this can be a very effective way of
taking multiple sources of information
of data
of music and merging them such that we
can create something new
the next one we'll look at is
recombinants which we
kind of looked at a little bit with
markov chains
in this example i'm going to take um
bags coral 140
break it down into individual beats a
beat
just a couple of notes or play together
a chord
and simply shuffle them around
and pick a random order which would
obviously sound absolutely
terrible because random order would just
not work so we need a direction like the
markov chains which
use just pitch we need some way of
knowing that the music is progressing
one way of doing this is using the
leading voice trying to find a nice
flow with the various notes do this
by for every single beat storing
i guess a little data set which
indicates the notes that beat starts
with
and the destination notes the next beat
what those notes were and from this we
can kind of construct this nice little
representation
of voice leading which is just comparing
the start and the destination notes to
create something that's easy to look at
for this example beat which starts with
five three five seven
six two six five pitches i talk in
pitches because that's actually the only
part of music i really understand um
we have ideas about what beats that
could map to there's a
like three or four examples there of
beats and from this
we can then start to construct beats
using voice leading we might get an
interesting flow better than the markov
chain
and this is an example so i'm going to
just run through
using box coil number 140 i
load a huge database broken up into b
groupings just because i used functions
or
depths for my data because data's code
encodes data
but there is a limit to the size of a
function so yeah
simple these are all midi notes i'm not
going to detail many notes but
it's all using a piano they have
different velocity involved as well
i load the data set it actually takes
quite a while
not too bad i get lots of nails useful
response but it's now
created an entire database broken up in
beats and in music
each of these outputs here
represents a b group and the specific
beat within that group
so you can see not just my word for it
but this is mixing and matching
a lot of beats and
i think you know i've actually listened
to some of the pieces this generated
and i kind of like it something
beautiful about it but again it's taking
bark's influence
i cheated though and this is a recurring
theme of creativity
um when i showed you aaron the painter
it generates
50 or for the 10 20 pictures overnight
and then harold cohen goes and looks and
picks the best ones
so there's a human there right there's a
human helping the machine
select what might be good that problem i
told you about the beginning of the hard
problem is knowing when you've hit gold
a machine a human is helping in that
example
in this example i discovered there was
something just not quite right with the
pitch distance every now and then
some couple of pitches crashed and as a
human this was
like instantaneous to me i instantly got
yes there's something not right there
and it was very easy for me to fix
something
as a pattern of creative machines is
there's this
ineluctable small little kind of bundle
of
random humanness that's incredibly hard
to
put down to a machine and none of the
people i'm talking about are claiming
that they've created
a completely isolated black box that is
capable of creativity
humans are involved and just to show you
what i did
and happily hold my hand up this is what
it sounded like
before i cheated it's not too bad but
it's bad
yeah it's it's just
so so many things and it took so so long
to write that it was
i was quite happy with it for a little
bit
we've looked at very specific data sets
about like bach
we've kind of haven't really captured
that aspect of creativity
of all the influences of when you took
that bus journey home that thing you
heard in the radio the thing you listen
to on your um
phone all those various influences that
come into as a part of creativity
and you know just taking a source of
bark isn't really doing anything
that you know bringing lots of new
different data sources
so one simple idea is to create a bot
that goes out crawls the internet
and finds all midi files it then does a
little bit of validation on those midi
files
and uses them to influence various
pieces of music
at the very simplest level we can kind
of use that recombinance technique
but with lots of different sources i've
got a couple of midi files that i went
out
and searched for and found midi is a
horrible platform nothing you hear is
actually
normally midi it's coming through
overtone makes it sound
there's a lot of electronic mixed in
there
it sounds pretty bad again but there's
something very interesting going on
their blending genres so
you can see how we could take that
further in
actually having a tighter refinement on
what we select
but i had absolutely no idea that it
would pick those pieces of music
and that's interesting in discovering
something new from the machine that i
never actually programmed it explicitly
to do
the final ones i want to touch on are
probably the most important
that david cope has implemented
learning and inference nothing we've
done so far has learned learning is part
of improving part of getting better
and inference is that key step
in taking a jump that might produce
something new but isn't necessarily
sound
graduas is a canon builder
and it uses a very simple depth search
with a number of rules about what a
valid canon is
and as it progresses it stores rules
that
it found problematic and in future runs
we'll avoid them so this is a very
simple example
it actually wasted a lot of time trying
to generate these results
with the search
oh yeah we have lots of different
sources
i fire it up again after i've done
overturn to shut up
we can run it again and it will build an
even better cannon
because it's learnt now a number of
rules
about paths that it shouldn't follow
past that it should follow
building up notes that worked notes it
didn't work it's encoding inside itself
a set of rules about canon
the other one um inference is the key to
what we'll see in a second
these are simple predicates about notes
gbd ce our dominant tonic dominant tonic
resolutions fac ceg our subdominant
tonics
subdominants are resolutions it's great
like i don't understand any of those
words
but i understand logic and inference so
i can actually understand what's going
on
so these simple ideas we can now ask the
machine to do something
give us an analogy for geb and don't
worry you can't quite see it down there
but it's got the fact that that
notes gbd
ceg the relationship between those two
notes and
f a c and c
c e g are related
[Music]
this is absolutely fundamental to
what we're going to look at now the idea
of building up
not just predicates though but building
up an association network
of adding weights to those associations
david cope very much looks at his um
his work with the composer will look at
as more of like
of jamming of like giving it a set of
notes and it's kind of responding
and then him going i know i didn't like
that i did like that
but with that inference step it can
take um it can take preconditions and
come to new conclusions that
aren't necessarily sound and that is
absolutely
key in creating something that's
creative
and this is where i step aside slightly
and
show you um what a lot of these theories
we've discussed
built um with david cope's creation
which has um
released a cd as well emily howe
i'll let you listen for a second
[Music]
i think this is beautiful and it's using
a lot of the techniques we've talked
about about
recombinants there's a lot more there
but i'm happy to discuss and dive into
later
[Music]
so i've kind of taken you on a little
journey through art
through music there's lots of other work
in poetry
um lots of other fun things about
creativity
but i kind of want to come back and the
question that i threw out when i started
can machines be creative
and we should let ada love lace lay a
little bit of truth on us
a machine it can do whatever we know how
to order it to perform
and has no pretension whatsoever to
originate anything
this makes sense everything i've shown
you has been based on source music has
been taking existing music
and trying to build music from it david
cope's
very hypothesis that music is based on
combining
various other pieces of music other
styles together fits with that right
um i kind of guess i would argue in the
response to this
is no human being has any potential to
originate music if they have absolutely
no knowledge whatsoever of music
i could not possibly begin to create any
of the piece of music you sound if you
just put a piano in front of me
i've been teaching myself musical theory
along the way and it's been
painful but she does have a point but
maybe it's the fact also
that creativity doesn't come from a
vacuum it comes from existing
input existing stimuli and maybe if we
create complicated enough systems they
may do things we don't expect with
serendipity discovering new sources of
influence
the not conscious argument is a hard one
as well
consciousness is often argued as a
fundamental for creativity
you need to be able to reflect on the
rules of the system you need
that transformational creativity you
need to be able to redefine the rules
and come up with new ideas and
it's it's agreed the machine is
well it's not conscious it's taking
a lot from the conscious the
subconscious model
and it is reflecting it is learning it's
just not at a human level it's at a very
tightly defined
um scope so we may be simulating
consciousness but it's also tying the
fact that maybe we don't need
consciousness to be creative
maybe the human way of being creative
isn't the only way to be creative
this one always makes me sad i do i like
a lot of work in ai
and this this this idea that
all this beautiful code that you've
written and sculpted and wonderful
variable names and beautiful fluidity
the machine has absolutely no
understanding of that
all that detail is for humans the
machine has
not no idea and again to me this falls
on that common trait of
assuming that it has to do things the
human way
a machine doesn't know what your
variable names mean
but a very low level it has an idea what
a what a
jump is what a condition is comparisons
operators left shift right shift
these very very low level things are
something the computer does understand
does have
meaning to it and i would argue
that that is operating at some level of
meaning
it's not the human level but again i'm
not sure being human
is enough to just say that's the only
thing that's be labeled too creative
the hardest and the one that i can't
possibly begin to answer
that's that beginning thing about
romance about the fact that machines are
the only things that can be
creative that's right humans are the
only thing that can be creative
so it's past my coffee time and it's
it's midnight yay um so
non non-humans can't be creative it
takes human to be creative
and you can use that definition but
i kind of think this is a little bit sad
i've
hopefully shown you some music that at
least i think is very very beautiful
and to deny that its place
in art seems to me like
rather short-sighted it's a beautiful
piece of work i don't listen
to art or watch art or view art
for creativity i view it to be have
emotions and
to explore what that work does in my own
mind it doesn't need a human to do that
i said creativity has many definitions
and coming back to my original question
can machines be creative
well it depends on what definition you
use of creativity
which kind of implies that we don't
really understand what creativity is
which also kind of implies we don't
really understand what's going in our
subconscious mind
so my original point of cam machine to
be creative
is kind of like me saying this thing
that we don't really understand
machines can do that which doesn't make
sense
so i can't argue that machines are
creative
because i don't know what creativity is
people do not have an absolute
definition of creativity
what i can tell you is the machines can
create
and what they create is
is not bound by the ability of the
programmer
i told you i cannot for the life of me
create music
but i managed to make machines that
could maybe get near to generating
music so my ability as a musician was
not impacted it was my ability to
express ideas
and that's interesting when it comes to
creativity it's not
the machine that has the limitation it's
the human that has the limitation
it's really about my own creativity in
my head
and the ideas that i come up with to
express to a machine
how it could go about creating music and
there's something kind of beautiful
there as well about
exploring our own subconscious and
trying to be as creative as possible
to create a machine that can create
beautiful things
and maybe feed off our creativity it's
really
an insight into our subconscious mind
and david howell cohen um
all these people um have discovered
amazing things
about their art form um harold cohen
spent
three years teaching aaron to
mix colors and he
realized after these three years that it
was a mixing color is just about
lightness and darkness
he'd known this subconsciously since he
started painting
but he could not express this to a
machine because it was that subconscious
expertise
so a part of creating machines is again
understanding and exploring our own
subconscious
if you could do me the favor of
listening for the next 10 seconds or no
so
and i put this question to you
if this machine is
not creating art what is it
and other than origin from something
human creates
how is it different if it's not
thinking what is it doing and if you
think
you are thinking what are you doing and
how is it different
let that float with us
[Music]
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you